j'imagine tout s'est tenue avec daniel
braud ça serait pas mal on soit peu
l'influencent britney spears plante est
donc un petit côté écolière mais rebelle
genre qui se met au fond de la classe
côté radiateur mais qui est quand même
qui est quand même dans le chat doré
regardez regardez ce magnifique hip hop
ou pas voilà alors là elle portait une
petite bracelet en cuir de vachette
non c'est très beau et ça c'était une
magnifique tu es vieux tu te considères
tournée solo moi je sais effectivement
avec ce petit clip à mon avis tu n'as
pas dû rester sous l'eau longtemps
ensuite vous avez une époque plus
maritime un petit 6 regarder non mais ça
ne s'est pas mes vêtements
c'est un déguisement pour il en sort la
terre oui pour la vitesse automatique
noir la terre de yannick loin exactement
voilà c'est ça qui s'étaient déguisés
comme sa part à la chasse à la palourde
9e mais j'aime pas ça vous va très bien
sur les connaissances hiver ça va très
bien j'adore à la casquette de type
chauffeur de taxi j'adore single rock
anaqua musette avec ça il était naturel
calme mixeur excès oui il est excité
gavroche avec la moustache merci moi
c'est bon merci heureusement en 2010
c'est l'année de la maturité mais de
passer en mode femme fatale la vie à 10
kilos c'est quoi cette petite robe c'est
du velours lisse on al'occasion de
l'occasion de me faire prêter des
vêtements donc je m'amuse avec ses
magnifiques serais tu te force à tout va
toutes ces annonces et au festival de
cannes s était allé y avait alors créé
nabeul c'est allah yar maladie que
j'embrasse ou non il est mort
[Applaudissements]
et
j'envoie
[Rires]
ok on n'est pas au bar en 2012 c'est un
des grands moments de ta carrière
un véritable tournant puisque tu vis ta
première sélection avec l'équipe de
football du brésil
regarde c'est le fou de concert mais
même comme ça même comme ça tu es frêche
je vais t'appeler martin côté fraîcheur
conscience des gens mais je te jure est
très regardée un autre délire là et un
autre mutin nous tu la joues hyperclasse
working girl avec une nouvelle coiffure
ça c'est mon appel à elle j'aime bien
c'est ce qu'on appelle la coiffure
gaufres est sévère car j'apprécie les
aurait toujours là mais je dois
développer sur toi c'est beau ça c'est
toujours du mal en fait à me voir en
photo mais a répété mme arena magnifique
je montais loupe dans the voice h
alors the voice kids who the voice à
chaque fois on a le droit à des tenues
de dingue c'est un défilé pour ali
après regardez ça c'est des ouvrages
2017 2019 2003 lit un arrêt sur images
j'adore et aux nma 2019 alors l'achat ne
s'est pas séparé sa femme c'est beau ça
diallo qui dit qui dit je suis papa
[Rires]
quand on a le bout de leur nez
je sais que je t'aime et samedi vous
êtes allés chanter dans danse avec les
stars
oui avec un look seventies et encore on
en a pris commercialise jadot c'est toi
qui choisis toutes les tenues du 20 août
à quelqu'un qui te conseille je choisis
avec sylvaine qui m'accompagne depuis
maintenant presque 20 ans mais serra qui
m'a énormément appris sur les modes sur
la clôture aux statuts coiffure où elle
me donne les compte beaucoup pour moi
eh ben pour moi aussi et je te dirai que
si je te dirai qui compte beaucoup pour
moi j'aime c'est injuste parce que
j'imagine tout s'est tenue avec daniel
moreau ça serait pas le même
deschamps
[Applaudissements]
son style et daniel moreau est une très
belle femme j'ai envie ce matin en
bureau
sachez que mon sang n'a fait qu'un tour
les créateurs se bat pour pour habiller
jean ismaël et icône de mode elle est
présente et on commet toujours s'est
tenue ces sorties et mais c'est vrai la
mort et se battre je répète je sais mais
je suis gentil merci beaucoup mais je
redis pardon mais vraiment je m'amuse
avec les vêtements
après je ne recherche pas l'avis unanime
j'ai besoin de me sentir bien dans le
vêtement et de et de voilà tout juste le
jeu selon les émissions selon ce que
j'ai remarqué de ce que j'ai fait j'ai
besoin de calme et les matières nobles
ces enveloppes pour être aussi beaux
tous les jours je vous dirais delphine
delphine disent ah oui mon conseil est
franchement depuis que suis avec elle et
je voulais en sait beaucoup de la
chemise avec ce que tu m'as dit en
arrivant je risque pas de rentrée
genève alors je te trouve se trouve plus
plus affûté que jamais merci fois encore
ta palahniuk on m'appelle le couteau
suisse dans le métier
[Musique]